do you work in a creative place maybe
you're a filmmaker or an author perhaps
you're an artist or an actress
maybe you're an app designer with the
lowdown whichever cultural or creative
sector you work in the European Union
can help and that's where creative
Europe gets going creative Europe offers
people like you yes people just like you
the chance to gain funding and support
for your projects this would mean
working with partners in other countries
support could come in the form of
training or it could be audience
development yes
creative Europe can help you tap into an
audience of more than 500 million EU
citizens not to mention billions more
around the world are you ready for a new
opportunity then make sure you get
involved how does it work once there
were three programs for applying to this
sort of thing but to save you from
getting tied up in knots there's now the
one-stop-shop creative Europe not only
that but we've reduced the paperwork for
applicants so the process is quicker and
easier to top it all the total funding
has increased to more than 1.4 billion
euro but you might be wondering what
this means for you well say you want to
train the team to switch to digital
technologies we are there if you're
looking to increase your audience we're
there too yes creative Europe can
support marketing and circulation of
work across borders
in film alone it would take several
months of non-stop viewing to watch all
the features expected to be distributed
with this funding if films not your
thing it could be an animation video
game work of fiction or concert we help
you get off the ground maybe you want to
get a successful novel translated so
readers across Europe can enjoy it in
their own language
after all creative Europe plans to
translate over 4,500 literary works or
you might be more interested in shining
a light on the original creative Europe
runs prestigious awards to draw new
audiences to the best creative talent in
architecture music cultural heritage
literature and filmmaking even cities
can battle it out for an award on the
European scene and each year we award
the title of European Capital of Culture
to two cities and the best thing about
creative Europe we fund projects of all
sorts of sizes involving any cultural
and creative sector it doesn't matter
whether you're a two-man organization or
one with a thousand members you can all
benefit from creative Europe are you
ready for a new challenge with so much
to offer there's bound to be something
in it for you
to find out more visit ECE Roper EU
forward slash created - Europe or join
the conversation on Twitter